okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is one of a long series
of meetings talking about how to polish
functions in Wolfram language which have
been experimental that might be
considered part of the permanent
language going forward and since we like
to maintain compatibility so far for
like 30 years we tried to be quite
careful about what we do experimental
eyes um all right so our first topic is
quite a big one it's about I know on
that framework and we've got tons of
functions here but where should we look
to understand the bigger picture
Sebastian so so I guess the bigger
pictures there's different classes of
functions here so when I live well
socially this page yeah exactly
okay it's anything non-experimental on
this page of the neural net stuff okay
so the higher level functions which use
neural nets are not experimental but the
functions which are the low level
representation of your own that's are
considered experimental yes exactly
okay and what is your proposal about
what to do
so the proposal is that all the layers
are going to be the experimental eyes
with the understanding that the design
will change in certain ways for 12
so the mainland design but why the heck
are we due to parental eyes in them okay
are we doing that well what if they kind
of change them but after 12 you say they
won't change anymore
is one will change right so so what is
that propose let's take a typical layer
let's take linear layer for example fur
let's talk about what I mean the thing
that continues to bother me somewhat
about this design is
this is this is a story of symbolically
represented tensors of various kinds and
you know to me it's not obvious I mean
this is a very kind of minimalist
representations of tensors and I guess
my question is how does this relate to
other kinds of you know symbolic tensors
I mean this is there's nothing
particularly okay so I mean if I say not
initialize of this okay what is that
same so if it doesn't know what the
template sizes then it doesn't it
doesn't know how large the weights are
gonna be so if you say input goes to two
or something
not my favorite I mean so the question
is why is this not okay fair enough
dandy okay so I guess the the major
issues at the moments with this so the
first thing is that it needs to have
time for the output so we want to you
know it takes we can take in like a
lists but we really want to make that
all the layers I'll put the right type
so if you're doing this what is the fear
okay so these are internal tensor with
symbolic tensors okay so the input type
okay but how does this relate to the
type system that Jose has been building
in the Tom has been building it does not
relate to us so it's a completely
separate system yeah there is a question
that's valuable for he wrote the system
okay well it seems to me that's a
question we need to answer because I
mean to my understanding you know
basically this is a representation of
some you know function that I mean what
the analog of this independent of neural
Nets just thinking of this as a I mean
you know the idea that we have you know
a net chain where we can for example
let's say we take line 18 let's say we
take table of 18 five times for example
by the way we've got a bunch of
background noise that we shouldn't have
um okay so if I say five five for
example this will um that work that
should work and that should give us a a
great big thing that is a series of
these earlier layers right I mean if I
were to say to two then I could make a
nice little plots presumably but I'm
trying to understand what the analog of
this is independent of I mean in other
words if we just think about this as um
[Music]
okay if we were to just think about this
thing as a series of functions right
there's a composition of functions of
some kind what is the relationship
between this net chain and a just
generic composition of functions which
is what we talked about even you know
multiple years ago before we were before
we started building all of this stuff
did you understand my question so it is
just a composition of functions except
that these things have little parameters
on them as well
I understand but so you know as things
move forward right what's learn about
becomes what you know the the the space
of things that are considered learnable
gradually increases so I mean these are
functions with with presumably I mean
these particular
have weights which are somehow learn
about yes Chris
exactly and you know if we tried to say
take this thing and we tried to say net
strain you know let us just do something
just to understand it let's take them
sample of resource data of M nest
oops comma 500 or something okay by the
way how are we doing it at making all
these some progress indicators
consistent have you finished your work
with that I've not been holding that at
all who has been working it's the resort
system so Bob really I think so much had
a personal ah so obviously I can't do
that but it's not expecting images ok so
there's multiple problems there no right
okay but but but be this as it may I'm
still trying to understand the
relationship of this thing I mean you
know a lot of this is is nice and quite
economical the current phase of neural
net of the neural net world it is
unclear to me whether it's you know
built for the future it's also unclear
to me what the future of the neural net
world is going to sense that I guess
yeah we have plans exactly for that so
basically things are becoming more sort
of functional based definitions so that
you basically would write a program with
variables and the whole program is
differentiable so the sort of syntax for
other sorts of frameworks like my torch
is what people sort of copy and so the
idea for that would be that there'll be
some sort of scoped constructs so the
current proposal is net function and
insight net function you can basically
you know your layers will be like in the
module and the so what these are like
these are like lambdas what we have
right now are things and what you are
proposing is something where we have
named variables hanging around exactly I
should say just to give an idea of the
other big picture there's like two
directions one is to be able to create
differentiable
functions you know more or do you say
with more freedom so that's what this
net function would be and you can put
whatever you want inside and the other
one is to have alternative training
procedures training loop so to speak
because right now it's very simple it's
you have something that the differential
and you have a lost function in
minimizes loss yep but for problems such
as you know generative adversarial
network or in reinforcement learning
it's a different paradigm it's not just
minimizing a loss function and adding a
differentiable function so to describe
how you would talk about what that
framework is so I mean the solution is
not entirely clear I mean okay just to
give an idea of other problems like like
with the generalized network you have
two networks right okay so you have one
generates one classifies yeah the one
that classifies it would be just a
simple training loop you know the data
to be classified and for the generative
it would be to put the classifier inside
the loss function of the generator and
so you need to alternate you need to
train a bit the generator or train a bit
the classifier then train a bit
generator and so on and so this is not a
natural fit for net train where you have
just a loss function that you want to
minimize so so roughly what would we
have that so so basically what it is is
some I mean it's a multi network it's
something where the loss function
depends on the training of another
network it's not really a loss function
but kind of I mean there's a training
I mean each of them have independence
loss function and the result is how I
mean - depends on how you know how much
you train the first network and then you
train a second network and depending on
this training procedure it will give you
different results
no I understand okay so what do you
imagine that the function that
represents this adversarial Network
training things will look like I mean
lady let me see I think and talk about
it there was an idea I mean we had an
idea of linking that internet train
yes akima yeah so we actually had a very
long design sort of discussion during
the conference about this and we think
we've actually come up with something
quite nice what is it so it's just a you
know there's two different approaches
you can take to this problem so one is
that you can you can drop down to like
what pi torch does or something like
that
and in that case you basically writes
differentiable functions and it's up to
the user to update the parameters you
have massive amounts of flexibility but
it is well so as you talk about what a
discernible function looks like no but I
mean let's talk about what a function
looks like what a differentiable
function looks like so let's say
something like this which has you know
couple of parameters here and we have
parameters which are you know we have
two kinds of parameters we have sort of
the you know input output parameters and
we have the trainable internal
parameters is that correct yes and this
is potentially yeah other parameters
inside the nurse might be fixed internal
parameters as well this is a true yeah
um but so in rough terms we have you
know we'd have a function I mean it's a
little bit
how this would work I mean so there's a
there's two kinds of things here there's
the there's these ones which are
potentially I mean I don't know whether
these are given but let's say these are
the training parameters and these are
the you know ultimately it's going to
return okay at any given moment so what
you do is you say say one of them is
like to say is the convolution air so X
is equal to convolution air so that's
not a stateful object that you can use
in multiple parts of the network okay
but it could assign you potentially a
tensor example let me enter a yeah it
could be a bunch of weight exactly
but I'm trying to understand here what
the way we think about it because
ultimately what we've got and this is
relates to how our layers work as well
because our layers are in a sense
representations of differentiable
functions where their differentiability
is not declared so to speak making sense
so in other words in a situation like
this the fact is it's got a bunch of
differential parameters in it and
parameters and you can get the
derivative of the parameters with
respect to you know the input on the
right well okay so so the thing I'm
trying to understand the directions to
go in one is I mean right now this is a
bunch of function compositions basically
which have implicit differentiable
parameters in them if I'm if I'm
understanding correctly
that's correct well each year exactly so
each layer is differentiable and then
the whole thing is differentiable quite
but in a sense if we had a way I'm
trying to understand in you know let's
say we have a function here let's say we
have function X you know x squared plus
y okay now we could imagine
differentiating that's what happens even
if we if we try and differentiate that
with respect to Y how bizarrely confused
if I'm not mistaken what happened there
I'm just totally confused
what that did well I mean it's teaching
as a symbolic expression x squared plus
y and then o is the cultural derivative
that's right it's a partial derivative
and so it takes okay so just to be under
what that will do
the heck is that doing
oh that's differentiating DX by dy
because it doesn't know that X is
supposed to be a parameter independent
of and we can tell it that by giving it
by saying that X is a constant with
respect to that differentiation exactly
which I'm sure there's even an option to
do here
oh I see but now if it's a constant then
when you differentiated it will give wow
that's really confusing okay okay so
explain to me what this is supposed to
do so in a sense there should be a net
derivative here
yes so basically yeah I guess the one
one difference here is that obviously
you can't symbolically differentiate
this necessarily
mm-hmm so it would return some sort of
differential function that if you give
it some inputs it will return the
derivative so at the moment obviously it
uses its net ports gradient we have this
idea I mean like for example if I say
you know the zeta function Prime at
point two point three right exactly you
know that that is a thing which you say
the derivative is valuable but we
couldn't get that by saying you know D
if we say D Zeta comma X it exactly does
something like that which one we
substitute X goes to two point three we
get the actual result yes so I mean the
point that I'm making is I think
particularly when you're starting to
talk about things where we have named
variables representing as essentially
the threading of these layers that we're
doing here and with net graph is a
threading where we are you know it's
like data flow of some kind right as
opposed to something where there are
variables which are defining the causal
network of the of the program if I'm
making sense so what we're doing here
what we're doing is something that we've
not done we consider doing this a few
years ago for functions in general that
is I can say F of G of H of X right but
in principle I could define just like we
do with net graph we could define ports
for functions and we could say here's
the graph that represents how data
should flow between these functions and
they're making sense that make sense
okay so we decided what was it three
four years ago something like that maybe
more to not implement that for general
functions we had a design but we decided
not to implement it do remember that
primarily Italian myself who worked on
this I see right so but the point is
that that approach is a sort of
interpolation between the kind of thing
because right now what we're doing with
layers is very convenient for layers but
it does not relate to other kinds of
things we do and if you and you know as
soon as we're implementing arbitrary
function layers and so on I'm wanting to
put in other kinds of things we're going
to have to address this issue and I
think we're gonna have to bring closer
what we have with layers to what we have
with other kinds of functionality and in
terms of what to do with so okay
that's my point of view and I think I'm
simply not convinced that we're ready to
be experimental eyes these things and
what what what is the proposal for what
to change in version 12 so the proposal
is one of them is puzzle what type it
returns so at the moment it's returning
a list of numbers but we want to have
support for numeric array that the
defaults is that returns a numeric array
of type float 32 then if you say what
working precision goes to something else
and it will return that type
what will return that type the generic
layer exactly Wow it requires some time
to return and it's highly inefficient if
you have to convert backwards and
forwards between yes a but I mean this
is then look you're going you're making
something lower and lower level here so
look the things that seem to me the
issues right now
one is correspondence with the other
type systems which you have not resolved
right do you agree that that's an issue
it is and then particularly for
specifying the type so for certain
things like this is pretty simple right
the input you can just say it's some
dimension
if it's a more complicated things like
some relays you know they have
restricted integer types for example
it's corresponds with dataflow for
general functions that is the notion of
you know relationship between a graph
graphs and function evaluation which we
have in the case of neural nets but we
don't have it in the case of graphs am I
making sense
maybe I'm just explain the graph case
okay so so they don't know on that right
if we say net graph what we have in that
graph let's look up documentation maybe
they'll have a nice minimal example um
there's a good minimal example well here
what you're doing is where's an example
let's see do we have we have a more real
example here short description Hanson
welcome to gate things again okay here
we go beautiful was magnificent
okay so this kind of structure could
perfectly well have arbitrary functions
that is it could be the case that here's
a function f that returns two results
okay here one of which is fed to a
function G she returns two results one
is fed to H you know like this and these
things could be F G H whatever now a
thing that we have not done and this has
shown up in in the quantum computing
case as well is our functions don't have
a good kind of canonical way to return
multiple results I see which is
happening here we return these returned
associations with the port names no no I
understand but that's a that's a
perfectly good general pattern that can
be used for quantum computing or can be
used for other things as well and in
general one could imagine you know a
style of programming in which the you
know the returns from functions are fed
to other functions we have a very good
version of that which is function
composition right but what we don't have
is something like this if you wanted to
do this if you wanted to write this
where these are general functions F G H
etc there is no good way to write this
right now
now I seem wrong right now on the other
hand this thing here could be written in
terms of variables
correct exactly right so we've got three
different versions of how that
computation can be represented one in
terms of variables one in terms of you
know these kind of graphs and I suppose
a third in terms of the actual net graph
thing that's been implemented so far
okay and my claim is that that has to be
unified just as what's happening in the
quantum case has to be unified with this
do you know what's been done in the
quantum case not much so it's worth
looking at because it has the same issue
it typically has you know end to end
functions because it has to be you know
[Music]
unitary transformations but I see right
so look my point of view is we need some
it's a very interesting design problem
of merging so I mean we got okay the
type issue we've got the issue of how we
represent this kind of dataflow thing
and then the other the other thing we've
got to do is this kind of sort of I
don't know what you call it you know the
hyper function of net train right is is
one way to is one form of okay so
there's an analogy right we've got
things like net fold and so on which is
some kind of higher order functions
operating on networks so okay net strain
is even a higher order it's some kind of
hyper function that operates not on the
structure of a network but on kind of
the the way the network is used does
that make any sense I mean it's just
like in functional programming right we
might have um I mean that's that's the
in functional program and we might say
okay you know we've got nest um that's a
way of using what am I trying to say
they you get what I'm saying I mean net
train is a is a version of what one does
given a network it is a particular way
of taking that network and doing okay
another it's a way of using a network
and what is an efficient way of changing
the weights of the network
what that so it's it's the only
efficient way of changing waste of the
network to something new it is a way of
taking so the way to think about it
probably I mean again we don't really
have a concept
with a function like a pure function the
notion that we are going to
incrementally monkey around with the
inside of that function is not a notion
that we particularly have right there's
the case where we're doing that but it's
not that's not something that's come up
in other cases
I mean I guess the sort of an minimize
type things are somewhat similar like
you have some parameters actually a good
example be find fit
it it's a good case where that I mean
that's a pattern to find fit is a
pattern where we have a generalized
function right um and where what we're
trying to do is to fill in well okay
that that that
yeah probably would what's the other
thing that we have um or find an
arrhythmia recently right what this is
doing then we could have represented
this differently and we could represent
this with I mean so let's let's look at
what it would take to have find fit be
what would find fit what would the net
train analog a find fit be janasthana
I'm saying right so what that's saying
is the net train analog takes this
function ax log B plus C ax right and in
your net train world a B and C are not
named parameters they're things that
would be you know what you would have is
something like I mean let's let's say
fungible function a bad name okay ABC of
a function and again that this is not
well named particularly but let's just
go through it to see what what the basic
idea is declare is in the function yeah
right
and then then what would happen is then
what find fit would do if find fit is
being told you know this is the training
data um whatever it is I mean it's
probably going to have to give it so
it's it's being given training data
which says this you know x equals 1 goes
to 2 x equals 2 goes to 3 3 goes to 5
etc etc etc etc right
the kind of that will be the pattern I
mean this idea of a function that has
parameters that can be modified is a is
a perfectly good general idea relevant
like find fit that's that's the kind of
a net function idea right is that you
know we need to try to unify that with
other things we're doing so for instance
here the you know it hasn't been
convenient to represent see this could
be perfectly well convenient I mean you
know having a function that represents
the fit here it's perfectly reasonable
thing to do rather than having explicit
parameters we have to get values the
parameters and so on depends what you're
doing in this case um I mean in a sense
interpolating function is a little bit
like this except that interpolating
function is not incrementally updatable
am i making sense I really think this
conversation needs to tally but you you
get more or less where I'm going and
exactly we're going the general yeah it
might make sense to yeah to make this
into Google doesn't the language better
right that's my point so I mean I think
that that the tendrils here are we've
got this kind of whatever fungible
function whatever you call it right um
it's almost like a parametrized function
which is another concept that we
actually have don't we um parametric
function alright so what is a parametric
function and how does it relate so
that's a little different
right but how does it relate see here so
this is a function that has a parameter
yeah what's that
it needs a parameter but what this
parametric function is is that
parametric function arguably is the
fungible function which is then going to
be fed the explicit values ABC and then
going to return a function that is the
actual sort of feed-forward function if
that makes sense yep right because this
function still has loose parameters
hanging out just like this function
still has loose parameters hanging out
okay look okay so look this is what I
think we need to be thinking about so
this is one direction is you know
whatever we're calling it fungible
functions and so we've got parametric
functions by the way is somebody here
taking notes about these these issues I
mean this really kind of derailed from
what this isn't really as I expected
this is not quite a we're just going to
make this function not experimental and
I don't think we have who is project
managing your own that works stuff these
days Trishna okay well I'm making notes
and I can relate them to Sushma please
do um okay but but so so anyway one
direction that we got weird background
noise here which I'm suspecting is
Sebastian's fault um you know One
Direction is doing better with this
fungible functions concept okay the
other direction is this data flow for
functions
okay knitting functions together hmm
okay and actually let me let me write
that down separately because this is
really um I'm gonna put this but let's
actually save this someplace in my so
yeah he just email this to me as well
yeah I will um
actually if I look in my neuron that
framework I'm sure we have the old notes
from four years ago about although you
know we've got a huge amount of new
experience since then and that's true
right which is what we kind of expected
we kind of expected we're going to build
something which is specific to the way
neuron that's work right now um okay so
so then here we've got this notion okay
so let's let's look here so that um um
okay so then we've got this what we're
calling fungible or parametrized
fungible differentiable whatever you
want to call it it may not be
differentiable etc functions okay
actually a better term here will be
Metta functions so these are functions
that are that are things like net train
okay there are functions that operate on
these other functions so that do a
pattern so for example find fit would
probably be an example of such a thing
if it was set up to operate on this sort
of fungible function ok net train is the
same way now what you're telling me is
that something like you know ganz is
some is yet a different pattern well we
we think we can fit internet train with
a slight modification from that train
I'm sure so yeah so it is a net train
can have instead of so the current
design is a net train the first argument
is the net that you can have a list of
nets good well that's interesting but
then is it a fixed training network here
and then you need to declare kind of the
there was a training procedure for this
net okay well so then then tell me about
that meta meta function which is the
training procedure okay ready is really
a patent for this which is generating
functions so that can either be a piece
of data what can be a I'm sorry what a
generator functions what so yeah so the
second argument can either be some
actual data or it can be a function that
if you supply
I feel like an active-active
classification for example active
classification has this generator
function feature that correct I think so
we'll know better right so okay so a
generator function but in it's got to
know what it's still pretty funky but
it's got to know kind of where the
arguments flow in in these networks so
things
function is that if you if you give the
generator access to both networks for
the current state of both networks then
they can use you know so it's a
basically that've Afghans will sample is
that one of the networks you know it
generates lots of figs and so it means
you know it's the network the
discriminator let us try and see whether
it's fake or not it needs to have access
to the other network but when I
generates things to generate some
training data for it so there's some
real examples plus some things you've
like hallucinations from those yeah I'm
paying to see some some discussion
recently about cuttlefish as Gans you
know cuttlefish have this weird just
large right um so you know who knows you
in a way are they but they say there's
an evolution the evolution is exactly
similar to training procedure of Gans
because of potatoes are the
discriminators right so but explain to
me then what does this actually look
like for for a Gans setup so the guy who
looked like yes it'll be two Nets yup
and then it'll be two generators so
we'll be listener of either data or
generators okay okay what does the
current one
so generators are pure functions that we
give them an association and that
Association contains a bunch of
information so things like what the
batch size is that that train is using
and also things like the current state
of both networks you can it comes with
okay so if we look at active
classification for example it is being
given its function is being given
certain things right yes we
being given second arguments I mean the
first argument is is Oracle function
well in the space of input of this
function right okay so in that case
what's happening here is this sampler or
the or the region defined here is giving
the set of possible inputs the that F
can get all right listen let's let's not
continue this right now we've got other
things we do in this meeting but but I
think I mean know this is the challenge
right is to merge these ideas and to
come I think we're not far away from
being able to do this actually and I
think if you know we kind of needed
tally for this it's kind of annoying
that that didn't logistically work out
today but why don't we come back and
look at this again when tally will
actually show up and I think we might
want in this discussion it might be
useful to have possibly Roger um
and conceivably Jose
but again I'm also very keen to
understand so this thing about yeah we
do need Hosea sure because this relates
to the quantum framework stuff
because I really want to understand this
this question about you know you have a
graph the graph has nodes the nodes
correspond to functions you know how do
we evaluate that graph because that's
what effectively we're doing in the case
of a net graph make sense program this
graph exactly right and it would be the
same for probability programming thing I
agree right another another thing that
has to be merged with this yeah right
I mean because that's what that is I
mean by the way you know the reason
programs as graphs and programs as
graphs is obviously equivalent to
programs with variables o less powerful
but more interpreter Bolen well no I
mean it look with graphs you know the
problem with a graph is
you know you have to label the only way
we know to represent graphs you can say
here's a graph right as an abstract
thing but ultimately the only way we
know how to symbolic eyes grab lling
nodes even if we label the nodes with
integers or something we're still
labeling nodes the graph could have an
existence on its own but the only way
you know is it's it's a little bit
similar to what happens with lambda
functions and shuns and know the
function has an existence on its own
with with arguments and so on but the
only way we know how to really engage
with it is to label those arguments did
that make sense also the issue that that
a graph is kind of fixed so as soon as
we're doing that labeling was sort of
equivalent to having variables but we
feel better about having a graph with a
thousand nodes that are you know
numbered from one to a thousand then we
do you know having variables x1 x2
through a thousand with with names like
that or am i confusing something did
that make sense it makes sense but but
just a servant problem is that easy yeah
do you hear me
Jamie I hate you guys
oh I think Stephen doesn't hear any of
us hello anybody there
do you hear us hmm okay you see what I
can reset something here because I can't
hear you honey we also heard I don't
know if you had also there's a little
bit of breaking yeah so that's maybe it
can be a sign that's really strange
investigation um okay so what was your
response to - um now I can hear you fine
that makes sense
another important things is that a graph
is kind of a static structure you know
you cannot have conditionals like you
know if statements and loops and these
sort of things so that'sthat's all the
limitation which is actually for neural
network the main limitation for NLP and
things like that where you have things
of various lengths you know when you
want to generate trees for example you
know that I necessarily balanced okay
fair point
I mean it's it's like you're saying the
structure of the program that the you
know the data flow in the program is not
modifiable yeah
but it all Vedas yeah exactly
so basically exactly so the program at
runtime it's fixed with a graph but yeah
and from your networks like the recent
sort of things have used
run time it changes the actual graph
right but so for things like
differentiable programs and so on you
can have programs whose execution trace
changes depending on the data processing
different I mean there's a there's a
final thing which is the actual program
changes based on data see for example in
you know genetic programming for example
the the concept was the program changes
somehow in reality those things have a
bad habit of degenerating into just
having a few parameters and you know
what's that that's a train to change the
program mean the data well I understand
that but it isn't real because all it's
really got all it is really changing is
these pre setup parameters see I'm
saying I mean you couldn't principle you
could look in the space of all possible
symbolic expressions that represent
programs and you could go as we have
done on a great big search in that space
but this isn't exactly true because if
you have to make execution then you know
there's an if statements and the weights
change a bit and suddenly the if
statement gets triggered now and that if
statement has a completely new you know
Co path so but but that is not but you
had to build that in you know in other
words the you know in some sense the
trilobite already had to encode you know
humanity so to speak if I'm making sense
right within the trilobite somehow there
had to be a nascent pathway that made
you know human-like eyes or something
right which is of course not the way it
really - yeah we could also imagine that
net train as instead of having a fixed
network or even a net function something
that capture a broader family look the
issue is is it possible to kind of go
exploring in the space of all possible
functions or other functions pre
parameterised
right and what we're saying is there's
different levels of pre parameterization
one is that the thing has a fixed graph
fixed execution trace graph and you know
fixed data flow graph and that's the
level so it's very important I mean I
think that would be an extension of this
fungible function but we have this
function that has three parameters right
and then we could have one that doesn't
have three parameters but arbitrary
number of parameters and you know sort
of I mean we include the definition of
the space of these parameters well
that's one way to think about it I mean
look the main issue is code equals data
is actually true for you know for a
symbolic language like ours and you know
it is in principle possible to you know
imagine learning in that symbolic space
not what's done right now right not what
we know how to do we don't understand
differentiability in a space of
functions like that we understand
differentiability in a space of
parametrized functions but not in a
space in the sort of arbitrary symbolic
space of functions so might be just too
restrictive for us so there's a sort of
way that people do this for example like
looking for newbs apologies and networks
is using reinforcement learning which
has no restrictions for
differentiability yes I understand yeah
so another thing with respect to that so
obviously in the world of cellular
automata for example we have the feature
that we are just looking at an arbitrary
space of functions right there's no
there's no sense in which I mean in that
particular case well that look there two
levels of function we could look at one
is take arbitrary Wolfram language
expressions another more modest thing is
take arbitrary cellular automata okay or
arbitrary boolean functions now the
boolean functions have a representation
that is you know in terms of an x' and
always and so on that will be we will be
hard-pressed to kind of explore that
space by just you know tweaking ands and
ORS it's so
happens that that space has a has a more
sort of explicit representation that we
can in principle explore but actually
first question with respect to
reinforcement learning and its
relationship to things like learning
cellular automata which don't have
is there anything interesting that one
can I mean you understand what I'm
saying that show nothing sense and I
sure sure I think this will be an
interesting experiments I don't know
I've never seen in the literature of
others but I alright something for the
summer school you're coming to the sea
right this year yes okay we'll add that
I'm gonna add that to my list for
somebody to look at um hold on let me
just remember to do that um hold on one
second here where are we
all right here we go a big long list of
weird things um let's see reinforcement
learning okay bill any case let's
interesting comments on the livestream
here one comment from Michael Hale is
isn't data flow graph programming like
what happens in system modeler that is
true
good point um I mean that's yes another
so in system modeler the way this is
done is we're representing you know we
have name variables we have graphs but
we are labeling the graphs using name
variables that is that that's another
really good point of something which
should be unified here um do you know
what I'm talking about
Sebastian ain't no faking this I haven't
used this model much at all
well I mean so if we look at an example
here and see what we can do here um this
is kind of this function is crazy
which is why it's experimental still it
will be much cleaner in future um but
let's just take an example here of how
[Music]
come on wake up
take so long well I guessed loading in
all kinds of crazy stuff okay once you'd
use the cloud where its pre provisioned
at least one
okay which we pick um took physics we're
supposed to know a little bit about that
and to try bouncing balls this by the
way might have some nice reinforcement
learning environments as well that was a
good point
what it's a something just live in the
summer school yeah that's a good idea
um it's a good idea
in fact that needs to be added to the
list as well hook up system modeler as a
reinforcement as I as a
[Music]
um as reinforcement learning
environments actually what's interesting
about that um is you know being able to
find the analog of interpolating
functions because you know what system
model it does is it finds um you know
given given some particular area these
example let's try introductory examples
here
what are we looking at component-based
alright whatever this is block circuit
here yeah so I mean a circuit diagram is
a quintessential example of this type of
thing see how do we actually get this
paste copy the model um but now you know
so what is the analog of the graph for
this how do we get something like the
graph well answer we have a bunch of
equations that represent that graph that
happen to be nasty differential
equations but I wonder where the UM
interesting yeah good point I mean you
know what is the analog of this though
this is not thought about okay so what
happens in a case like this is this
graph defines a bunch of equations which
are then solved for the state of the
system
to there being a feed-forward mode in
which see the analog of the feed-forward
mode
boy it's interesting analogy
um anyway okay I don't think we have to
let's let's not go down this particular
direction right now um
there's a another question here on
livestream somebody was disappointed
that Bayesian max Bayesian men were
never able to optimize complicated
choices in neuron that design are we
working on something like en ASE which I
don't know what it is a TN can you
comment on that I don't know what Ian
NAC okay
well but any case that the question is
um being able to use Bayesian minimize
etcetera to change parameters of neural
nets what is the story with that and how
does it relate to I mean that that's
again relates to this meta function
question because this is you know that's
again one of these patterns for how you
can change of things it's like an outer
loop right okay so they otherwise no one
is outer loops right so the question is
what outer loops how do we think about
this notion of outer loops in I mean
this is kind of the the slow what what
am I trying to say I mean this is a um
you know a very minimalist outer loop
would be something like a select among
cellular automata for you know among
some list of cellular automata for ones
that have some particular property
that would be our minimal kind of
exhaustive search way of doing something
by making sense and these things here
are attempts to have more you know
incremental outer loops
so there's you know exhaustive search
type outer loops or various kinds of
evolutionary outer loops
okay this thing is called efficient
neural architecture search fire
parameter sharing and we're being given
a reference for this which we should
look at um do have you heard of this
but in
let me look at it deficient because I
don't have a link oh here I'll send you
there you go um
you
you
okay someone else was commenting earlier
one challenge you may need to solve to
unify everything as how to symbolically
compute gradients of functions networks
using vector matrix operations I think I
mean the wrong group of people to talk
about that I mean we're we're I can
actually answer this cookie okay so
there's two different types so there's
two different types of differentiation
in the literature
so there's symbolic differentiation and
basically you have you know if every
variable that you've got you're gonna
have one expression for that so if you
have a thousand parameters the network
you know have like a thousand two rigid
expressions but automatic
differentiation is quite different from
that right that's much much more
efficient right that's what we are
implicitly doing all over the place
exactly but we have not made it explicit
for a broader class of functions which
is an interesting thing to think about
doing it's a very general technique is
not just neural networks right what
we've implicitly used it in all sorts of
places I'm sure we implicitly use it in
system modeler we just haven't exposed
it because we don't have a good
packaging for it at top level all right
listen I think we should wrap this
particular segment here I think the
conclusion is we need to talk about
these more general issues and let's set
up a discussion for that um
okay and then I will send on this
notebook um to to folks who are relevant
to that all right we're gonna turn to a
complete limit what's this the net
encoding at Dakota well we're not going
to do these if we're not if we're not
doing the layers we're not going to do
that for the encoders and decoders what
on earth is this this is why is image 3d
image 3d is not oh that's a net decoder
right yeah but I mean these things are
it's it's unclear to me I mean is there
any general discussion that we need to
have about these things these are these
are things where we're basically just
taking you know it's the I don't know
it's it's it's our modern analog of
girdle numbering in some sense
take anything and just turn it into a
bunch of numbers for a neural net and
when I sing coda yes I net yeah okay
well in that decoder is the is the
inverse of that exactly so it's finding
a numeric representation of some other
type yeah it's I there's never a new
idea Under the Sun that's the same as
gödel numbering in some sense
um except it this is a lot more
practical um so a question about this is
how general so I mean you know the issue
is it matters a lot what the encoding is
whether the neural net is actually going
to be able to learn nothing and so on um
and you know what class of types are we
able to do this for and what is the
matter way of thinking about what the
encoding ends up being for different
types
does that question make any sense yeah I
think it's a reasonable question
so I think for certain types like images
it's pretty clear there's a numeric
intenser representation and your neural
networks want to act on numeric tensors
so it's more interesting for so audio
the same situation well the things that
have space and time as a as sort of
features of them have a very clear
notion of how they can map into
something where sort of space and time
are preserved sure it's less clear for
example when you have a tree-structured
grammar for example it's a little less
clear you know there is a ultimate
temporal sequence but it's less clear
that that's the important thing
this is a discussion at the moment for
like how it deals graphs for example
yeah good question so I saw that the
have you figured that out have you got a
reasonable representation there have no
set time yes yes people try to do that I
mean it seems to me it depends a lot
what the graph is gonna be used for and
what it what it represents
sure so physical one thing you might
wanna do is
was of like a cetacean Network so you
have a network of citations and then one
node might be missing and you want to
say given the surrounding nodes predict
what's the missing node will be we did
that we had that project at the summer
school year or two ago of our see also
citation Network for the for our
documentation
I do remember vaguely this project
that's a cover the details yeah but
that's it so let's take that as an
example of where you want to use a graph
as the thing that you're working on
um-hum example you know taking a graph
and then predict something about is
thing to do is just take the adjacency
matrix and just say I mean the problem
is that an adjacency matrix there's
either an edge or there isn't and it
doesn't tend to be the case that it's a
sort of differentiable thing where
there's 0.1 of an edge or 0.95 of an
edge sure that's the same so you can
take if that's right you can threshold
it perfectly well just as you do for
lots of other neuron that operations
exactly and the special convolution
types that act on these adjacency
matrices that the gloves developed okay
so adjacency matrices are one approach
and presumably the sparse matrix is that
there's a sparse representation of the
graph has to operate directly on the
sparse representation of the graph so
things like MX netsupport space
operations for yeah for purposes like
this because I mean what what what is
the encoding you know when you make an
incremental change the sparse
representation of a graph what do you
end up with I mean when you make an
incremental change the additions to make
sure it's pretty clear what you end up
with sure that's a good question and so
well you think about it I mean you know
you could they're basically two things
you can do you could spawn additional
elements nonzero elements or you can
change the values sure
tricky part is that's how do you prevent
just all the elements becoming just
spawn or the whole thing like he needs
fresh holding or never might be messy a
differentiable nicely right and it's
also not clear you know what does it
mean to spawn nearby I mean you know
another way to think about this actually
would be okay so here's another way to
think about it maybe um you know the
question is what changes do you think
you want to make to the graph as you you
know you're trying to modify the graph
right so how do you make incremental
changes to a graph so the answer is
that's not particularly easy
you know there's graph rewriting type
stuff which one can do which is pretty
hard to define but that's I mean the
most obvious way to make an incremental
change to a graph is to rewrite some
local sub graph as something else but
then the question is if you want that to
be done by a neuron that how do you boy
that's complicated because you know as
you change the number of nodes you're
completely changing any operation that
changes the number of nodes the
adjacency matrix representation is not
going to help you very much
so okay so that's an example of a
difficult case um yeah these are cases
are things like you want to classify
some graph as being yeah and it's a
chemical that is a reactor we're not
reactive as things Alice
well this in chemicals there are smile
strings and things like that which I
would suspect you can treat probably
very much like sort of pieces of you
know like linguistic sequences
without having you know one-dimensional
linguistic sequences maybe with some
tree structure without having to address
the whole graph theoretic you know setup
yeah so there's gonna be all kinds of
approximations of the graph that
amenable to some the question that I
have here is we've got all these random
net encoders my question is what's the
general way to think about that you know
the general way is you've got some data
structure you're grinding it up into
numbers yeah all right well look let's
move on because we're not gonna we're
not gonna resolve these shopping um
right now all right well I think that's
it for you Sebastian and I think we're
well actually hold on we are now on to
hoe boy yep that's this is another
complicated area here okay um
do we really think and I'm afraid this
is not completely unrelated do we really
think text element is ready for
primetime
well um the draw has the roads but can
we met in a different design I mean well
yes we've got several related things
right so this is what's relevant for
abstract syntax trees right which is I
mean this is effectively an abstract
syntax tree for human language that
we're dealing with here
you know I don't think the reason I'm
not happy with these yet is we haven't
had enough experience actually using the
results of you know text structure for
example it's true it's true so we a lot
of feedback of people that just didn't
know that they can use a structure we
also had feedback of people using the
structure and being pretty happy with it
I know I've seen that too the which is
good I mean always what one wants to see
but you know the question is is that the
best way it can be done I mean I think
it's a reasonable way to do it I think
it's not you know I think it is usable
um you know the other case that we
looked at is okay so we also had this
long-running project to do the analog of
text structure for code write C code for
example um and I think that there are at
least preliminary results from that
right where you're annotating a piece of
C code or for that matter a piece of
wolfen language code using this kind of
abstract syntax tree type notation that
makes sense
in other words you're annotating a piece
of C code you're saying this is an
identifier this is a declaration this is
or whatever it is this whole thing is a
gosh I'm forgetting my C syntax names
but it you know is a is a clause or
something whatever that makes sense hmm
and so there's an analogue of this for
that um
I think we kind of need to look at now
with respect to text structure why on
earth do we not want that the experiment
lies word translation that seems to be
one big a case that is rather
straightforward what is the problem with
that beside my function I don't know
well the fact that it's not your
function doesn't mean that it I mean I
don't know but Alan was finished I think
so who Raj what was the story with word
translation right Alan didn't get back
to me yet about what translation so I
just left it as is I think that one is
actually one that can be the
experimentalist
I'm not confident about text structure
because I feel like text structure
depends on the text element business
which is pretty good but I'm not
completely confident about it like for
example one of the issues here yeah I
mean really is pretty good but what's
happening here um
what has happened by the way to our on
that version full neuron that version of
text structure takes cases what does
that text structure I thought we were
also gonna do a puzzle that way no no no
we never had that I thought we were
discussing that a multilingual puzzle
that way know if there's been
confusion about there was there was what
was it about part of speech like like
lower part of speech tagger yeah speech
and also about a norm international norm
too you know because like but it ad
position business to represent you know
prepositions and post positions and so
on yeah but we never had the idea of our
self training like multilingual part of
speech or text structure type thing okay
but I think we also were discussing the
possibility of for example generalizing
you know this this business about
replacing the preposition tag with an ad
position tag which is utterly obscure to
anybody who knows you know who's used to
English it's utterly obscure mm-hm
and I you know what would be again wrong
group of people here but what on earth
is our approach to doing to dealing with
that because if text structure returns
specifically preposition I mean I think
it would end up having to have some
option in this form thing yeah that's
the right way to do it this this form
option should be able to say whether it
is internationalized or not we're making
sense mm-hmm anybody here know a
language that has post positions
No okay fair enough
um we don't have enough people in the
meeting eventually we'd have have enough
people that somebody within our language
with postpositions okay
why are nothing we know at the
experimental Ising snippet Raj is that
another one what people didn't get back
to you know there is a comment there
okay yes I think what we're saying is
that you weren't sure if the content
object search result object so there is
a use case for that in the documentation
but we don't know if that part is going
to stay the same
the other five is a horrifying case
right so that's giving you a snippet
that is contextualized within a Content
object saying this is the sentence where
the word you know cuttlefish or
something was mentioned yes and do you
believe that that yeah okay so is this
working right now is this how you do
those snippets in the search results yes
and what aspect of a search result
object is the thing that is used to snip
FI the content object there the query so
it redoes the query in some sense on the
content because you need additional
query
I see so on
if I took a Content object so if I had
done a search for cuttlefish and then I
insert a completely new content object
in the snippet that happens to contain
or not what happens if it doesn't
contain cuttlefish itself at this time
okay let me go through this again let's
imagine that the search results object
which contains the original searched
cuttlefish okay doesn't yes you know
that's fine so we put it in there as a
second argument of snippet okay but the
first argument of snippet is something
that had nothing to do with the search
result object it's a completely other
piece of text about oak trees okay yeah
what happen if there is if there is no
cuttlefish in that content object then
there will be no snippet okay so in what
sense why are we even bothering to put a
search result object here if all that
we're using from the search results
object is its search terms why isn't it
just a list of search terms why don't we
have a form where where what we're
effectively doing is to say you know for
the snippet why don't we just say
snippet I mean that seems like a
perfectly reasonable thing to do snippet
piece of text
comma search term yes the scene takes
the whole the COPE query that can be a
complex thing in account search terms so
that could be you know that we could
equally well say a query here but we
don't have to have the results you're
saying that the thing is going to
research so to speak this text is that
right because because what's happening
here this is a specific use case where
it's like a search engine where it has
already decided the page you want out of
the billion pages that were fed in the
page you want is this content object
page and now you're searching within
that content object paid to know where
the relevant snippet is yes yes okay so
let's walk through that again because
essentially the general case of that is
you've got a piece of text and you're
snipper fiying it by some query right
which is stiff less than the case that
this is the minimal case okay so let's
walk through this so in the case of text
search we are used to the idea that
we've given many files and we are saying
which file contains our relevant you
know piece of text there's a different
thing we might do which is which I don't
know whether we have a way to do which
is give me the surroundings I mean it's
more like text cases give me the
surroundings of this word in this
particular piece of text am I making
sense do we have another way to do that
but isn't snippet right so I think this
is not right I think that the correct
version of this would be and the syntax
that we certainly can still support is
something as simple as this right yes
the issue here is that to get the full
version of this we're going to need a
search term and I mean you know arguably
this the correct form might be something
like this where we've got a search term
and we've got a number of lines see what
I'm saying it says what that would say
is centered on that search term I don't
know whether that's the right way to
represent it in the snippet but that
seems like a useful thing centered on
the search term show me a snippet of the
text some number of lines around that
search term maybe like an option like
not for a specific term right what
how much text around there that's what
the second argument is doing in these
other cases oh yeah yes that right so
what this is this is a good idea to have
something where we can have a
contextualized snippet and maybe the
default is you know if the second
argument is just a string
the default is I don't know some is is
whatever this default is whatever the
number of things is here so this will be
a much simpler way to do this where we
could as a courtesy so to speak support
feeding in a complete search result
object but the more minimal case would
be to have a search term and a search
term and a number of lines does this
make sense I think this is a good
extension to snippet step 3
okay well let's let's iterate that I
think I think this is the experimental
Iser the experimental eyes about 412 but
let's bring that back if you can look at
implementing that and and the details of
the design then let's bring this back
again so that one is not so Raj that one
is still in the running for the
experimental ization market and I just
heard back from Alan Stephanie or Greece
at what translation can be the
experimental ice okay so I agree with
that too
so let's just go ahead and do it do you
want to the experiment slice text
element and text structure no no I do
not okay at this point I think we've
still got some issues there I think the
most who is who is dealing with text
structure sure okay so the first thing
is this internationalization for
adpositions and so on and the second is
the correspondence with code structure
and actually the third thing is the
trees project and making sure that this
dovetails correctly with the trees
project so by the way word translation
the only other case that we need to
probably explicitly mention is the all
case we probably should mention that in
the in the primary documentation here
that's something for Allen Raj okay
I must say it's not a priority for
texture I mean it won't be for you um no
I understand it's fine yeah I just want
Jerome to think about it I agree courage
is a next thing text case well I mean
text cases has been way too fragile so
far yes I saw the Jerome's work it is
not we hope yes yes exactly exactly so
right now it's not the experimental is
able but hopefully 412 it will be in
some great progress I think that we have
a good data set do we like the design
there has been some voice
so that the output is an association or
agent of a mute you are making a noise
here um yeah yeah there's some yeah
there been some some some asking for a
different output when you have several
properties you know when when you put
form arrow prop and you put list of
properties and right now you can define
what the output is right now well the
all form you know like if you do yeah
it's really when you mix things so when
you say I'm on all the words and all the
noun so you could put like in the list
right now
takes cases word now and some people got
a bit confused because right it's it's
unclear I mean this is an outer product
question for you know if I say noun verb
right it's quite kind of unclear what it
should do and yeah right now it's gonna
be flattened so it's going to take I see
so it's going to be the alternatives of
that exactly it's like an alternative
it's exactly like an alternative at the
moment why did the Fox not make it as a
noun
I don't know can't write extra
but tech structure and text cases may
not do the same thing it's true there
may be a faster thing for part of speech
well there is there's a part of speech I
mean there's a specific part of speech
yeah I mean it's more reloading some
giant huh set up why is this so slow
what is it doing and if it is so slow in
Rogers an issue for you if it's that
slow it needs a loading indicator okay
I'll follow that up the Fox is a noun
how come the Fox got lost yeah we're
actually going to switch for 12 I
believe I think you're almost thinking
that switch - what - the same power of
speech that doesn't take structure or
two using the case when a wave every by
its text structure going to switch to
the text cases case or its text cases
construct text case is switch to the
text structure case okay well that's
good because then the Fox we already
lost yeah like I am a prior model we had
that is pretty fast but and some
problems yeah so that wasn't what I
think so I think I think we need with
Siobhan another meeting to settle down
this design it's something that by the
way how's that locked somebody I I
didn't know there was a verb form of Fox
I know there's a verb form out Fox but I
didn't know there was a word for phone
Fox anyway no matter go ahead please yes
I think we need a meeting it's also
something that that that broad as well
when he was developer of text cases this
thing of having
station and output and yeah me of being
and I'll change my mind about that but
which leads were switching to a more you
know having a session as an output when
you have several forum or several yeah I
think it's interesting to talk
Association itself we should we should
think about it branch of real examples
yes I mean this is analogous to other
functions which have multi you know
which have this out of product kind of
character of having a because you know
the issue here is both the form and the
properties yeah that's similar to what
happens in an entity value right yeah so
try to put a property phrase on noun
verb then now you put arrow and and then
let's put least yeah for example string
string and comma position for example
why is it giving me those weird
autocompletes
I think it completes for the 4-minute
for the property well that's wrong so so
that's another bug droid can do that
well it could do anything and so you see
that that's the sort of thing stupid
what it did there in that particular
case that's not completely stupid later
the first one is an alternative
basically and the second one is the
classic right but again I want to say
this should be analogous to what happens
with entity value
all right I need to go um so all right
we didn't manage to the experimental
eyes all that much but I think we made
some interesting progress on a bunch of
deeper issues and I you know Raj with
respect to these two experimental
ization meetings I mean I think they are
readily predictable which ones are going
to go easily and which ones are not I
mean I could have told you looking at
the agenda for this one this one was not
going to be a you know a rubber stamping
type meeting um and I can tell you with
respect to this I mean after this all
the other areas that are remaining are
areas which currently are recommended to
stay experimental so do you want me to
what's an example well I think it's
worthwhile to sort of kick the tires of
these things because you know the goal
is to gradually move them towards you
know final polished form and we don't
get to do that unless we you know look
at them and change them I mean like like
for example the neuron that stuff you
know we will introduce I'm sure some
higher-level understanding what's going
on and that will allow us to feel
confident about the experimental eyes in
them um right I know I sent you the the
agenda for the functionality that
supposed to be experimental why the heck
is audio experimental why is this oh oh
I see there are a few bits and pieces
there I don't think audio capture needs
to be experimental asked I have no idea
why that needs to be experimental I
don't know why
no these these are worth looking at
there's no reason that's I mean why why
for cookie store don't have any comments
that than those okay we through thee
does not need to stay experimental in my
opinion I don't know why this would be
experimental as nothing experimental
about it seems fine do you want me to
stick the text search with these
functions for the next meeting yes I
think the conclusion with text search is
going to be that we review it a bit I
doubt we're going to be able to do
experimental eyes it there but I think
it is worthwhile to review it unless we
decide Matt that's for you that we're
simply going to look at that in the in
the next text search review meeting when
is that supposed to be Matt bunch of
your time this week and I'm on PTO for a
week and a half now okay um okay in any
case there no we need to look through
these there are plenty of things here
which do not need to say exponential
okay I'm gonna hang up thank you
everybody thank you to people on the
livestream nice comments today much
appreciated